ghost of tsushima's director's cut is
out now bringing a proper next
generation version of sucker punches
open world samurai adventure to the
playstation 5. this is pretty
fascinating as the game has already
received a ps5 patch last year which let
it tap into the extra horsepower of the
system so you might be wondering what a
proper ps5 version brings to the table
while it's still largely the same game
there's a number of improvements that
makes ghost of tsushima's director's cut
the definitive version i'm going to be
focusing this video on the ps5 specific
improvements not the iki island
expansion which is also available on the
ps4 if you want to know more about that
check out phil hornshaw's review
let's start with the resolution the
original game on ps4 pro offered a
resolution mode where it ran at a
targeted 30 fps at a checkerboarded
1800p
as well as a performance mode where it
ran at a locked 30 fps at 1080p pretty
straightforward stuff with a simple
choice between picking a more stable
frame rate or a cleaner image
as i mentioned before sucker punch added
a ps5 optimized patch which allowed the
game to take better advantage of that
system the game would then run at 60fps
at 1800p checkerboarded while in
resolution mode essentially making the
performance mode obsolete but the game
was still the ps4 version meaning it
couldn't tap into the full potential of
the system the way a native ps5 version
can so what does the director's cut give
you according to sony if you select
higher resolution mode the game will run
at a dynamic 4k at 60fps digital foundry
has confirmed the game does indeed run
at a checkerboarded 3840 by 2160 so it's
not native 4k but it is really damn
sharp and a noticeable improvement from
the ps4 pro version playing it this way
also takes advantage of the higher
resolution textures sucker punch was
able to add to this version and of
course it runs at a nearly flawless
60fps the result is one of the most
beautiful games you can play on your
playstation 5 right now
but the game still does have a better
frame rate option as well picking this
puts the game to how the original
version played with the ps5 patch 1800p
running at 60fps but why even pick this
mode if the higher resolution also runs
at 60fps according to the devs they
actually considered leaving this option
out but because there is the potential
for a few drop-in frames to occur in
higher resolution they figured they'll
leave in better frame rate for those
that want the option of a locked frame
rate i will say that i never experienced
any frame rate drops during my time
playing on higher resolution and if they
do happen they're so minor that you
won't care so you should 100 play this
game on the higher resolution mode
now let's talk about the power of the
ps5 ssd loading times are fast and i
mean really really fast watch me travel
across the island here and load in
almost instantly
this is on par with what we saw in
spider-man miles morales which is my
benchmark for fast loading times this
increased speed also allows the devs to
do something rather interesting in the
original game a number of cutscenes were
pre-rendered as a way to hide loading
times but now every cutscene is rendered
in real time this was done to help bring
down overall file size as pre-rendered
video files are quite large but it also
allows for one of director's cuts most
welcome features proper japanese lip
sync a point of contention for some
players during the release of ghost of
tsushima was the lack of lip sync while
playing with japanese audio
considering the game's setting and how
playing it in japanese is featured as a
selling point when you start the game
this exclusion did hurt those looking to
experience the game this way because the
sizes of the pre-rendered cutscenes were
so big they could barely fit on the game
disc and didn't leave the space for
alternate cut scenes with different lip
sync now that the cutscenes are rendered
in real time this allows room for sucker
punch to add in japanese lip sync
musk
as somebody who played ghost of tsushima
in japanese this is by far my favorite
new addition it's still not perfect in a
few spots but it's a massive improvement
playing in japanese you don't find
yourself distracted by the lip sync the
way you might have been previously in
fact we have a video comparing the two
versions which you can check out after
this however there is an interesting
quirk i noticed that is a direct result
of switching over to real-time cutscenes
in the cutscene at the beginning of the
game where jyn recovers his sword there
is a flashback to him as a young boy
training notice the excellent match cut
between older and younger gin
however on the ps5 version the game
instead cuts to black and then fades
into the flashback the framing of gin is
also slightly different curious about
this change i reached out to sucker
punch and was told that this is indeed a
direct result of switching over to
real-time cutscenes
the reason the original version was able
to do that seamless match cut is because
it was pre-rendered while switching to
real time made cutting from these two
completely different scenes possible
thanks to the ps5's fast loading the
developers still needed to add a small
transition to make it work the
cinematics team had to go through the
game and tweak a few scenes as needed
while i prefer the look of that original
match cut i do think that sucker punch
made the right call here as the switch
to real-time cutscenes gave us japanese
lip sync something that i find more
important if anything this is just one
of those interesting examples of the
kind of changes made to a game when
adapting it to new hardware the
director's cut also gets expected ps5
features such as dual sense and 3d audio
the haptics ride that sweet spot of
feeling good without being too much
there's the obvious stuff like the
collection of swords or tension of a bow
but there's also more subtle effects
like your horse running on a rocky path
or feeling the wind blow past you
i hesitate to go so far as calling it
game changing but i do think it adds a
lot to the experience you even get some
sounds coming out of the controller
during cut scenes such as when jin
unsheaths his sword
other notable changes include the much
asked for lock-on feature which you can
turn on and off as well as some
alternate button styles great for
accessibility however these options are
included in a free update that ps4
players will get to enjoy as well
which brings up the question of if this
is worth picking up if you've already
played gosu fushima originally the
pricing of the ps5 upgrade is a bit
confusing to wrap your head around
buying the ps4 version of the director's
cut doesn't come with any of the
improvements we just mentioned just the
icky island expansion and for that it
will cost you 20 us dollars meanwhile
the ps5 upgrade runs to 30 dollars so
you're paying an extra 10 dollars for
all of these improvements and while i do
think these improvements do make the
game better and it's worth checking out
if you haven't already played ghost
tsushima if you've already played it
before it's a bit of a tough sell
however i leave it up to you to decide
if it's worth it a big selling point
might be the iki island expansion which
if you want to know more about i'll
remind you again to go check out phil
hornshaw's review spoiler alert you
liked it and if you liked this video why
not give it a thumbs up and sub to
gamespot for more coverage on all things
video games thanks for watching
[Music]
you